and it's very very rare where Dana White
makes a mistake of this magnitude he
made a royal mistake Ben against Francis
nanana to be fair as a businessman he
probably made the right choice in
hindsight now that we're here royal
royal mess up because you have the most
relevant fighter on the planet and he's
not with the UFC he has nothing to do
with the UFC matter of fact he hates the
UFC you had all these UFC
representatives there you had the
legends of the sport with Izzy Usman
Connor you had all these guys there and
Dana White's nowhere to be found when
they ask Dana H proba just go kid did
good that's it that's all you're going
to get out of them the most relevant
figh on the planet name is Francis zanu
and Dan has it is no part of it when if
you could have just played ball where
could have just been cool for once in
your life you could have been part of
this historic moment